we're getting prepared to celebrate
independence day uh
today's job news uh brought us uh
something else to celebrate this morning
we learned that
in june our economy created
850 000 jobs 850
000 jobs the strength of our recovery is
helping us flip the script
instead of workers competing with each
other for jobs that are scarce
employers are competing with each other
to attract workers
so let's bring in our panel to talk
about the economy and other lightning
round topics byron york chief political
correspondent of the washington examiner
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington post and steve hayes editor
of the dispatch all right byron i'll
start
with you you heard what the president
said there employers are having to
compete with each other to attract
workers some would argue
they're also having to compete with the
federal benefits that have been extended
to a lot of those workers
exactly look first of all the bottom
line is 850
000 jobs that's good news and and
presidents
often brag and take credit uh for
economic developments maybe if they
didn't have a lot to do with them
president biden took a real victory lap
today maybe two or three
victory laps today and really didn't um
take note of what we're seeing is that
you know that job competition has led to
rising wages
in some places but it's being eaten up
by inflation right now people are quite
worried about that
the price of gas obviously this holiday
weekend is just terrible all around the
country
so there's a lot of anxiety right now
that
economically that just was not captured
in this
victory lap that the president took
attributing it all to himself
and this massive stimulus bill that
democrats passed a couple of months ago
well steve against the backdrop of what
byron has laid out
the white house did put out a tweet that
says we're going to save 16 cents per
person at this year's cookout
a lot of people i mean if you if you
take a look at it it's being dragged
it's being trolled
heavily online um was that the best
uh decision going into this holiday
weekend when people are struggling with
things
like putting gas in the car yeah it was
a curious decision to
tweet that tweet i mean people can
people know
by what they see at the gas tank by what
they see the grocery stores
people understand and fundamentally feel
what's what
inflation is is affecting by their own
reality by their own existence they
don't they're not going to be persuaded
by a white house
tweet touting a 16 savings i think byron
is right i think the federal government
the role of the federal government the
role of states in ending
these 300 per week additional
unemployment benefits you saw
more than two dozen states mostly run by
republicans
moved to end these additional
unemployment benefits in may or
announced that they were going to be
ending
in early june there's a lot more to
learn as we dig
into the numbers but i suspect that
we'll learn it's no coincidence that we
saw this strong jump in jobs at the same
time
that we've seen these two dozen states
cut those off or announced that they
were going to cut them off and it's
important to know
too that nearly 350 000 of those jobs
came in the hospitality industry which
had been really struggling to find
workers i think precisely because or at
least in one
respect because of these additional
unemployment benefits
so that's at least part of the equation
here
and again to put up the hard data so
people can see um great news that we're
talking about adding 850
000 jobs but it was unexpected that the
um unemployment rate went from 5.9
that's where it ended up the estimate
was going to be 5.6
charles your thoughts
i think that 5.9 is a little bit of a
puzzle i tend to see it as kind of
statistical noise because
the broader unemployment rate that
includes people who are discouraged from
seeking jobs or involuntarily on
part-time that number went down
so there was kind of a mixed picture
there
i think the big picture on the u.s
economy is
positive i think we went into an
incredibly deep hole in 2020 and
thanks to a huge amount of federal
stimulus and federal reserve
bank stimulus we're zooming back out of
it
and by all accounts that's going to
continue through 2021 and into the first
half
of 2022 most of the problems we have
actually seem to be the kinds of
problems you have
when you're growing so fast that you
can't keep
up factories can't find enough uh inputs
especially semiconductors that can't
find enough workers
their bottlenecks all over the place of
people trying to crank their restaurants
and hotels back up
and i'll end that showing in a little
bit of inflation i'll be very very
curious to see
whether this in 2022 is the issue people
vote on
or whether people regard this comeback
as something that was kind of inevitable
once the vaccinations occurred but you
know we can we can argue over the
the wobbles in the data but the big
picture is very positive
all right i want to get a very quick
comment from you guys in this lightning
round about the supreme court wrapping
up its terms so we get to your winners
and losers but this idea that it has
not performed as some of the best and
worst predictions were for the court it
hasn't exactly turned into the
handmaid's tale and by the way
i got a list today from the court of all
of the clerks that everybody has hired
for the fall so it doesn't look like
anyone's going anywhere
charles start with you and then we'll go
to steve then byron
well just quickly on the point you were
alluding to the non-retirement as
at least as of now of justice stephen
breyer
you know if he stays on the court
another term i think some of the people
who are practically demanding that he
quit
ought to do a little soul searching and
think to themselves was it such a smart
idea to try to humiliate
this very proud man in that way yeah it
didn't work with justice ginsburg a
quick comment from you
uh byron then steve or steven byron
yeah look i mean i think what we've
learned from from this particular term
is that
the the inclination to divide the court
into partisan terms which has dominated
the media over the past decade plus
uh really doesn't fit in many ways in
this particular court where you have
institutionalists conservatives liberals
what have you
byron well on this
this flower shop case that we're
discussing tonight i think it's kind of
consistent with one thing with the
supreme court is that
they don't want to solve the issue here
they
in in the cake shop case in colorado
they issued a very very narrow opinion
now they've completely ducked this one
at some point they're going to have to
come out with a ruling on this
but so far they're ducking it yeah i got
to do it on the merits okay very quick
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else